hi there steve kaufman you'll notice
that my surroundings have changed i have
moved back up to the attic here
uh no longer sharing an office with my
with my wife
so i'm up here and i will continue doing
my videos from here
a few items i'll be in china from the
24th of october partly on my wood
business and also i will be meeting with
my
with the company that published my book
in china about six or seven whenever it
was years ago
and we'll be discussing the possibility
of a new edition to be published in
china
um
now today i want to talk about
uh listening
because i think listening is so
important
and because i think we can improve our
ability to listen we can become better
listeners and therefore better learners
now
i know that i often say you know we
should only use those those methods of
language learning that we that we like
doing
and some people don't like to listen
uh some people like to watch video
um
and and i admit that i
won't do certain things that i don't
like doing like doing exercises and
answering questions
even though they may be good for me
so what i'm going to say may fall on
deaf ears with some people
however
i
would like to repeat that i would
recommend to people if they ask me what
should i do okay you're going to do what
you want to do and what you enjoy doing
but if you ask me for my advice spend a
lot of time simply listening and reading
i know i've said this before but i want
to stress it again it's so easy to do
speaking of course is very important and
the more you progress in the language
the more you will want to speak and at
some point to make a real breakthrough
you have to speak and you have to speak
a lot but for a long period of time you
can make significant progress in the
language just by listening and reading
it's easy to do and it's relatively
inexpensive to do
but we do have to develop
the ability the skill to focus while
doing it some people can't read but the
more we read the better we get it
reading my wife didn't like to read
she'd fall asleep when she started
reading but she stuck with it and she
started reading more and more and then
she found books that interested her it
happened to be books about history
historical novels and now she enjoys
reading
um she didn't like playing the piano
when she had a piano teacher but now
she's playing piano on her own and she
plays more and more my granddaughter
granddaughter had the same experience so
the more you do something you can
develop not only do you get better at it
but you can
start to like it more
uh the expression that i often quote in
french la petite
the appetite comes as we eat
so
getting back to listening some people
say they have trouble concentrating
while listening i have said that i am
able to concentrate better if i am
listening while doing something else the
dishes going for a walk and i have had
people on my youtube channel concur that
that it's difficult to sit in a chair
put some you know language content on
and just sit and listen
it seems to be easier for some people
to concentrate when we're doing
something else it is also very practical
in that we can be
doing two things at the same time we can
take advantage of what would otherwise
be dead time one of my big criticisms of
rosetta stone is that you're forced to
sit there in front of the computer
uh now something happened to me which i
want to share with you i was listening
to
this uh french chancegne george prasas
who
i enjoyed i enjoyed when i lived in
france
and it suddenly dawned on me
that here i am listening to his songs
and i am totally focused on every word
and i remember that when i lived in
france when i was bathed in french i was
a student there for three years i went
to school in french spoke french every
day every day did everything in french
uh
and i haven't really had that much
french since then occasionally once a
year i run into french-speaking people
visitors or i we have been in france on
a few occasions and so forth but when i
was most
uh immersed in french i would listen to
these french chanson singers and i
wouldn't understand the words because
it's sometimes difficult to pick up the
words
and i found that i i understood
every word
and i attribute this
to
my commitment to
language learning through listening over
the last really 10 years it's 10 years
ago that i started working on my
cantonese using a minidisc player and
it's then that i discovered the power of
these very small
and yet very you know high quality
recording devices of course the mini
disc player progressed into the mp3
player the ipod and
android and all of the things that we
have today
so i spent a lot of time listening to
cantonese
korean
portuguese
russian and now czech and i have trained
my ability to listen and to focus while
listening
when i listen to check now
i hear every word it's not a blur i
don't know all the words but i hear
every word very very clearly
so what i'm saying there is some of you
may
not like listening some of you say that
you've
tuned out
uh some of you say that you prefer to
watch movies
all of that is undoubtedly true
i would just
recommend that you make the effort to
try to
get better at listening and focusing
while you're listening it's an acquired
skill and the more you do it the better
you get at doing it and if you have that
ability it becomes a tremendous learning
tool
in my view and i've mentioned this
before they should teach that as a
learning skill at schools
i even suggested partly tongue-in-cheek
that they have kids run around the
schoolyard listening to their lessons on
an mp3 player
you know i see sometimes the efforts of
schools
or universities to have online
courses and they all want to have like
an online classroom like the teacher is
there and somehow broadcasting it out to
many many people and they can get on and
ask questions and it's all very
interactive and so forth
and there certainly is a place for that
kind of interactive
learning process
but i believe a big part of learning
you've got to do on your own whether
you're reading or listening and reading
and of course we also have to develop
the ability to read and focus on what
we're reading because reading is such a
powerful way of learning not only
learning languages but learning in
general but listening is another skill
and we should
train kids to get good at listen listen
listen to five different versions of
the uh you know
something to do with say ancient
uh egypt okay
one ten minute
story another little lecture another
whatever and you listen and listen and
you hear about the same things through
different avenues uh different
perspectives and you're listening and
and if you get good at it then you can
listen while you're walking to school
walking back from school it's probably
too ambitious in terms of school kids
but if we can train that that is a
tremendously valuable skill we can learn
while in the car and we don't fade out
we stay focused so all i'm saying here
is listening
the ability to listen and of course to
listen just as in learning languages you
need words you need vocabulary and so
the in order to increase one's
vocabulary of course the combination
of listening and reading or if you want
to take it one step further the kind of
interface and support that we have at
link and no no elsewhere can can make
sure that the vocabulary grows because
to understand what's being said you have
to know the words it's also possible to
listen and listen listen and eventually
guess and figure out some of the missing
words but it goes faster if we combine
it with reading so there you have it i
just wanted to sort of get back to this
thing about listening yeah everybody
learns in different ways some people
like watching videos
but
if you really want my advice i'm quite
convinced
that for everybody if they can train
themselves they will learn better
and they will learn more efficiently if
they can train themselves to be good
readers but beyond that good listeners
and if they are good listeners they will
become good readers so listening
is key
in terms of language learning literacy
learning in general we have the most
wonderful tools now
for listening we have the most amazing
resources available on the internet
all kinds of interesting courses and and
audio material that you can download
learn to be a good listener
and that's what i wanted to say today i
look forward to hearing from you bye